nous sommes le 10 novembre 2016
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 et les invités rencontres avec
celles et ceux qui font l actualité dans
le département et aujourd'hui vous
entendrez henri guaino le député les
républicains des yvelines était
récemment aux dédicaces au chesnay pour
la sortie de son dernier ouvrage il
s'est aussi exprimé sur son
positionnement vis-à-vis de son parti et
il est toujours aussi critique à david
martin c'est un producteur heureux sa
société 16-16 drogue basé à plaisir a
signé un court métrage sur grand paris
au métrage primé à plusieurs reprises et
puis benjamin ball en le directeur du
développement culturel aux
clayes-sous-bois nous parlera du
programme des animations autour du
centenaire de la guerre 14-18 sa commune
propose expositions conférences et bien
sûr hommage
on débute donc par de la politique et
cette rencontre avec henri guaino
l'ancien conseiller de nicolas sarkozy
aujourd'hui député des yvelines se
montre critique envers sa famille
politique lui qui n'a pas recueilli les
parrainages nécessaires pour participer
à la primaire de la droite et du centre
entend bien peser 1 malgré tout à la
présidentielle et pourquoi pas à se
présenter et coûté le set au micro de
nicolas landry il serait difficile de me
mettre au dessous de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans l'est dans les
primaires oui on a besoin d'eux on a
besoin d'un sursaut dab besoin d'être au
dessus de ce spectacle absolument
lamentable délétère c'est c'est la
politique politicienne dans ce qu'elle a
de pire c'est aucun des problèmes n'est
pas menée n'est abordée quand il quand
un problème est évoqué il ne l'est pas
sérieusement parce que personne n'a
travaillé parce qu'au fond tout le monde
s'en moque
parce que le but ça n'est que de gagner
des élections sans savoir ce qu'on fera
après en tout cas moi je suis déterminé
à aller jusqu'au bout parce que je n'en
peux plus de faire de la politique en
acceptant
la vie politique telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui en acceptant de de débat tel
qu'il se tait lequel se déroule femmes à
droite comme à gauche
mais regardez les primaires de la droite
la droite et du centre
regardez ce spectacle quand vous voyez
des ministres des premiers ministres
venir critiquer avec autant de hargne
l'action d'un gouvernement auquel ils
ont participé ou qui l'ont dirigé
d'envoyer des gens qui se sont pardonnés
mois roulé par terre pour être ministre
et pour le reste est volé par faire pour
être premier ministre pour le reste et
qui se comporte d'une façon aussi
indigne pense que les moyens d'afficher
ses désaccords et moyens d'afficher ses
contradictions sans se comporter de
cette manière
pourquoi cette envie de toujours
catégoriser de toujours posé des
étiquettes
ça me rappelle tous ces imbéciles qui
pensent pardonnez moi que la demande des
deux gauchers que l'offre est de droite
parce qu'il existe quelque chose de plus
mais ce qu'il existe une idée plus bête
au monde que celle-ci économie ça se
fait avec de la production et de la
dépense à sec de l'offre et de la
demande et qui en général il faut
s'occuper de l'une et de l'autre parce
qu'elle ne s'ajuste pas tout le temps
tout seul automatiquement parce qu'on
n'est pas toujours en plein emploi parce
que les marchés ne sont pas parfaits est
ce que nous pensons vraiment que la
concurrence peut résoudre tous les
problèmes de l'économie et de la société
est ce que c'est bien raisonnable mais
ce livre dit que non ça n'est pas
raisonnable ce n'est pas raisonnable au
regard de tout ce que nous savons de
l'histoire économique de tout ce que
nous savons de l'histoire des idées
économiques
on parle du grand paris à présent dans
cette édition du 7 8 les invités avec ce
film promotionnel réalisé par une
société de production plaisir oise david
martin son fondateur est un homme
heureux ce film multiplie les
distinctions à travers différents
festivals propos recueillis par camille
lambert une commande de trois
commanditaires en fait au départ et la
société du grand paris
la préfecture d'ile-de-france et la
métropole du grand paris
donc nous on avait déjà un marché en
fait avec la société du grand paris et
ils nous ont passé une commande pour
réaliser un film qui avait pour objectif
d le film du grand paris est donc un
film un peu émotions voilà qui met en
avant plus l'humain que des chiffres
enfin il ya un gros travail de
l'image 3d et c'était aussi un gros défi
parce qu'on avait très peu de temps pour
faire ce film
ce film c'est fait la phase vraiment de
production pour la partie animation
trois quatre mois ce qui est très très
court avec la scène de la tour eiffel
qui sort au début c'est une scène
extrêmement nom d'une des plus chères du
film mince et c'était extrêmement
délicat faire donc il ya un gros travail
d'animation 3d
il ya la tour eiffel il ya les gars qui
sortent
il ya la plante qui pousse enfin voilà
il ya le lancer de peinture aussi la
première diffusion de ce film c'était
pour les ambassades de france dans le
monde entier à l'occasion du 14 juillet
c'est à dire que la société du grand
paris mettait à disposition ce film pour
qu'il puisse être diffusé dans les
ambassades
alors après le après la première
diffusion le film a rencontré beaucoup
de succès vraiment on a eu un retour
très positif des ambassades et on s'est
dit ce serait peut-être intéressant
d'emmener ce film un peu plus loin et
d'aller présenté dans des festivals
dès le départ on a fait le choix de
festivals internationaux on a fait le
choix principalement du festival de
cannes cannes corporate qui est la
référence en france au niveau des films
internet et à l'occasion de ce festival
à l'occasion du festival de cannes
on a eu le plaisir en avoir deux prix un
dauphin d'argent dans la catégorie
communication marketing et un dauphin
noir dans la catégorie prise de vue
alors dauphins noirs dans la catégorie
des prises de vue ce qui est important
c'est qu'on a eu en fait qu'un haquin de
dauphin qui est remis dans tous les
films y avait plus de 1000 films qui ont
été envoyés à cannes et en a qu'un voilà
qu'il a été a été récompensé qui a eu la
prise de vue la meilleure prise de vue
international
c'est là on en est donc trois prix quand
même
puisqu'on a eu aussi un trophée d'argent
deauville hélas le film est parti
maintenant à tokyo donc festival à tokyo
voilà la maintenance hors de france pour
les festivals donc il est parti à tokyo
où il sera présenté le 25 novembre c'est
un film ou css prod a vraiment eu un
budget serré pour donc c'était compliqué
et on a beaucoup donné par permis
énergie sur ce film donc c'est vrai que
c'est un film on y tenait énormément et
on espérait vraiment avoir des retours
positifs
on a eu des retours positifs on a eu en
plus des prix donc que du bonheur
j'accueille à présent en plateau
benjamin ball en bonsoir vous êtes le
directeur du développement social
culturel sur la ville des
clayes-sous-bois votre ville qui propose
de nombreux rendez vous autour du
centenaire de 14-18 qu'est ce qui a
motivé ce projet les clés de 14-18 ans
passés beaucoup d'énergie associative au
départ en fait hein mais il y avait
beaucoup de choses qui se faisait un peu
chacun dans son coin
donc l'idée de la ville c'était de
regrouper tout le monde voilà et de le
lier avec là aussi l'éducation nationale
voilà et d'en faire un collectif pour
qu'on soit à la fois plus créatifs et
qu'on fasse un événement qui est plus
d'ampleur et qui puisse toucher tous les
publics qui a déjà été organisée l'année
passée qui va se prolonger ensuite
jusqu'en 2018 on va aussi précisé que
l'opération était la bise est labellisée
par la mission centenaire qui distingue
à travers la france les les projets qui
justement sur le plus innovant vous
parlez du travail avec les associatifs
avec les écoles aussi comment réagissent
les élèves ils sont réceptifs sur ce
genre de projet je sors la cet après
midi d'une d'un spectacle septano mort
qui voile avec avec 250 collégiens dans
la salle ont abordé la question des
combattants étrangers voilà c'est
quelque chose qui les touche parce que
ça leur parle voilà dans cette danse est
france diverse
chacun peut se reconnaître dans un de
ces combattants qui a participé aux
différents conflits
donc oui ça des touches on a répondu
tous les cm2 aussi avec un petit livre
qui s'appelle petit quizz la grande
guerre ne soit il rentre à la maison il
pose des questions aux parents aux
grands-parents donc forcément ce que je
crois que c'est une histoire qui touche
encore beaucoup lu un projet aussi qui a
été réalisé par le cap à dos et puis
avec les seniors de la commune aussi
vous associer les deux générations
miroir d'histoire miroir d'histoire on
lui qui a été une création artistique
d'écriture et de mise en musique qui
était aussi liée avec un clic s'appeler
les graines de l'humanité qui a été
tourné dans le parc de diane et dans la
mairie avec des seniors et avec votre
concours puisque c'est lui qui nous a
soutenus dans la création ce clip les
clayes-sous-bois en 14-18 sur cette
période là ça ressemble à quoi
on passe était une ville de région
parisienne comme les autres par contre
il ya eu des combattants qui sont partis
et on a on a cette année la chance de
retrouver quatre combattants 4 poilus
qui n'était pas sur notre monument aux
morts pour diverses raisons
voilà on les a retrouvés grâce à
l'association cg vie et donc on va les
mettre à l'honneur en inscrivant cette
année demain
voilà on dévoile en leur nom sur le
monument aux morts ça arrive
régulièrement justement ce sera dévoilé
demain et ça arrive régulièrement que
qu'on retrouve comme ça des habitants
d'une commune qui participent et qu'on
rajoute leur nom bien évidemment sur le
monument je ne sais pas ça arrive
régulièrement ce qui est sûr c'est que
la création d'un collectif me permet
justement de retrouver ça parce que
au-delà de ces quatre noms on a
découvert que deux clés siens avaient
écrit des livres
voilà de leurs grands parents ou de leur
audience théoriquement aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas tout encore et encore des
choses qu'on peut découvrir apprendre et
que le devoir de mémoire permet aussi un
travail de recherche historique tout à
fait je crois que c'est vraiment le but
de la mission centenaire nous on a
orienté vraiment notre travail là dessus
c'est à dire à la fois cultiver la
mémoire locale des clayes-sous-bois en
essayant de faire ressortir encore les
choses qui pouvaient être ressorti et
puis en choisissant des thèmes forts
chaque année cette année c'est les
combattants étrangers n'est prochaine ça
sera la place des femmes durant le
conflit 14 18 donc ça nous permet
d'avoir une double approche
l'exposition qui se déroule en ce moment
permet de voir justement l'implication
des habitants des clayes-sous-bois on y
retrouve quoi à travers cette exposition
on va en voir les quelques images nous
avons réalisé un sujet et quelques jours
d'accord et bien on les retrouve à la
fois l'histoire de chaque fois luc les
siens une l'association cg vie qui est
une association de généalogie a beaucoup
travaillé pour voilà retracer l'histoire
de ces poilus voilà look où j'allais
dire et puis à côté on a sept cette
exposition qui a été maintenant
propriété de la ville sur l'ensemble de
la participation étrangère au conflit
puisque l'on sait que les combattants
sont venus du monde entier et en
particulier à l'époque de nos colonies
asiatiques africaines maghrébines voilà
océaniennes caribéenne et c'est des
milliers et des milliers de soldats du
monde entier qui sont venus combattre
dans la somme où à verdun du coup j'en
viens au travail qui est mené avec les
élèves ça permet aussi de les fédérer à
travers ses différentes identités vous
avez vous avez parlé à l'instant il a
aussi l'enjeu de cette mission
centenaire et du travail que vous menez
oui je pense que ça participe au
sentiment d'appartenance en tout cas
savoir de mon bien savoir pourquoi on
les entend on est ensemble parce que
notre émigration et cie vie à cette
histoire coloniale et à l'histoire de
ces guerres donc ça participe vraiment à
au sentiment d'appartenance
quels sont les autres événements qui
vont se dérouler au cours de ce mois de
novembre
alors dès demain on a on a trois
conférences qui sont organisées par
l'association cg vie autour de
l'artisanat autour d'eux
de verdun autour dé l'histoire des
uniformes le 11 novembre pour le nombre
de vendre demain ont dévoilé quatre
n'ont officiellement pendant la
cérémonie
il y aura des séances de cinéma autour
du film adama conraux diffuse qui est un
vrai support pédagogique pour les
parents et pour leurs enfants
dimanche à 15 heures il va pas faire
beau donc c'est l'idéal pour un au
cinéma voilà et puis après tout au long
de la semaine bien sûr l'exposition et
ce soir le spectacle tout public à nos
morts qui est un hommage un symbole
c'est un hommage du hip hop de la
jeunesse à ces combattants venus
d'ailleurs elle aussi et du métissage
vous parliez du hip hop avec cet hommage
et cette mémoire qui est entretenu le
site internet les clayes-sous-bois point
fr pour retrouver la programmation sa
fille chelsea à votre sur votre écran
numéro de téléphone et adresse mail si
vous voulez encore plus d'infos pour les
prochains jours vous avez évoqué le
travail qui serait mené sur les deux
prochaines années
l'année prochaine comment ça va
s'articuler vous parlez du travail
autour des femmes pendant 14 18 est tout
à fait parce que les femmes ont joué un
grand rôle puisque les hommes étaient au
fond donc tout le travail des champs des
usines voilà de 2,2 des soins ont été
faits par les femmes et c'est souvent
une histoire oubliée donc ça va être
aussi sous forme de cinéma sous forme de
deux spectacles d'expositions de
conférences qu'on va les mettre à
l'honneur et en 2018 on finira avec le
rapprochement franco allemand puisque on
fera une grosse boule en opération avec
notre ville jumelée en allemagne voilà
donc ça sera l'occasion aussi de se
retrouver et de et de conclure voilà ce
sera portée aux le travail qui nous
avaient mené ces différentes années
merci benjamin gaulon d'être venu nous
parler de ce travail etc les 14 18 c'est
en ce moment merci encore c'est la fin
du set 8 invités pour ce soir rendez
vous lundi aux horaires habituels demain
vendredi édition spéciale du 7-8 l'hebdo
avec nicolas kirillovitch une édition et
qui sera consacré aux attentats parisien
un nom après la soirée meurtrière au
stade de france
aux terrasses des cafés au bataclan
également et pour l'instant et
programmes se poursuivre sur notre
antenne